[MUSIC PLAYING]
IDO GREEN: OK.
Yeah?
Can you hear me?
This is not working.
Good afternoon.
Thank you very much
for coming.
We're really excited
to be here.
It's always a pleasure to be
in a crowd where people are
passionate about the things that
you are passionate about.
I'm Ido Green, and I'm
Developer Advocate.
DANNY HERMES: I'm
Danny Hermes, a
Developer Programs Engineer.
And I worked on the cloud.
IDO GREEN: Right.
And I'm the client guy
that will speak
about Chrome and HTML5.
Today we're going to talk about
three quite amazing
technologies that keep changing
in a rapid pace.
We'll speak about mobile, about
the web, mobile web, and
about the cloud.
And we thought to tell a story
that will take you through the
process that we went, we're
building a mobile web app, and
utilizing Google Cloud Endpoints
as our backend.
So let's first just start with
a nice little demo that just
will show you a macro
view of what we did.
So you could see this app.
And first and foremost, I'll
just sign in because we do
want to handle our users and
have the amazing photo that I
will save under my user and
Danny's his, et cetera.
We are here on the normal
network, so please, if
you are with us--
DANNY HERMES: Yeah.
Stop using internet.
IDO GREEN: Yeah, it would
help us a lot.
So I'm accepting.
I have this--
when it will finish loading.
DANNY HERMES: It's fine.
Just click Accept.
IDO GREEN: Yeah.
I did.
DANNY HERMES: Demo gods smile.
IDO GREEN: Yeah,
it's demo gods.
So basically, what we're going
here, it's that regular
process of what you do
when you sign in
with Google+ button.
And after we accepting it.
It's need to confirm and send
us the token back, we'll be
able to see the app itself.
And basically what we'll do, it
will fetch all the photos
that we have stored
in our cloud.
Now, the app itself is built
on top of a few layers.
And what we thought would be
wise is just to show you some
of the best practices that we
encapsulate and baked into the
app itself.
So the app itself will work
when finally we'll end
[INAUDIBLE].
It will work offline
completely.
So like any native app that you
are accustomed to, this
app need just the beginning to
do this, call to the server,
get all the assets, get the
skeleton, and let you work
with the app even when you don't
have connection, or when
you have flaky connections.
So one of the most important
features that we are able to
achieve here is that
the performance
will be much better.
We'll have 60 frames
per second.
The app will be really
responsive.
Everything will work fast.
And the user, of course,
satisfaction will be higher.
So apparently our network
here is not allowing
us to do too much.
So basically, I'll try--
maybe we'll--
DANNY HERMES: Let's do
it from the desktop.
Let's just pretend like we're
on mobile, sadly.
IDO GREEN: Yeah.
So this is our app.
And you have your status button
that just will confirm
to us when we are offline and
online, so you'll be able to
see it with us.
And I already signed in, so I
could do it pretty quick again
just to see that all the
process is working.
So I'm accepting.
The sign in button
has vanished.
And now I'm in the app.
I have here my photos.
And of course I can attach
and create new photo.
So one of the beautiful things
here is that when I'm taking a
new photo, here it will just
open the file chooser and will
fetch the photo, as you saw.
But on the mobile device, it
will actually go to the camera
itself and allow me to
capture and speak
with the camera directly.
And we see that we have lots of
device APIs through there
that are baked into the web
platform and allow you to do
quite amazing stuff when being
closer to the metal.
So here I have this photo.
I'll give it a title, a
description, and I'll save it.
One of the things that you saw,
it immediately saved it.
And then we got another
confirmation that it send it
into the cloud.
So basically, we are able here--
and here it was quite
fast, but if this was working,
you could see that
we have some lags.
But the beauty of it is that
we are confirming to the
client that the action
was done.
Our user doesn't really need to
be worry about it, and it
works much faster.
Now, the photo is here.
I'll pull out the
network cable.
And as you saw, it's
becoming offline.
And I could do the same
operation again.
So I'm going, I'm
adding a photo.
Let's add a new one, give
it a name, and save it.
Now we're getting confirmation
just that it saved locally.
And since we don't have any
connection with the cloud,
we'll save it.
We'll put it in a queue, and
later on when we do have
connection, and let's just
hook it up and see what
happened, it will know how to
sync it with the cloud and
actually enable us to see it
from different devices.
So if it was working, we could
have seen it here and here on
different screens.
And actually, you can see that
we're doing the best with the
real estate that the screen
itself is letting us.
So we passed the demo.
Maybe we'll move on.
Yeah.
So cloud and client.
So let's just have a little
role game here.
I'm the client guy, as
you mentioned, so my
answer would be no.
We don't need any server.
We just need it once to get all
the assets, and then we
are happy campers.
But before we do that, let's
just define to ourselves what
we see in a modern
web application.
And it could be web, it
could be mobile, it
could be both of them.
One of the things that we saw,
that all of them got one goal,
and they're trying to get the
user to achieve their goal
with the highest efficiency
as possible.
So they are very focused,
very contained.
We see more and more code that
is flowing to the client side,
and that's why we see it
flourishing in all the MV*
frameworks.
Basically, we're talking about
clear separation between our
data and our views.
We just want to be able to
maintain our apps, especially
when they're growing
quite fast.
Offline first, so like Eric
Schmidt coined the term mobile
first, we'll now try to term
and work with offline first
methodology.
So the app will work everywhere
in any case.
And it's true that we're in a
web browser and we are online
most of the time, but even in
cases where we are on a
submarine or airplane or flaky
connection, we'll still be
able to do the most--
with our app, like you saw, the
most crucial functionality
to take a photo is back there.
Device aware, you know that we
have now browsers as an open
technology on handheld devices,
tablets, laptops,
desktops, and TVs.
So screen size of 2 inch up to,
I don't know, 100 inch,
and you should do the best with
the real estate that the
device itself lets you.
Pref matters, it's a hashtag
that we're using through all
Chrome channels.
And we just want to emphasize
the importance of making the
app work best.
We all know that users love the
app to be responsive and
snappy, and everything should
work as fast as possible.
So cloud and server.
So if I'm playing the role-- and
please take my things with
a grain of salt here--
I could say hey, we have quite
a lot of amazing HTML5 APIs
that allow us to save the
skeleton of the app in the
AppCache to use local storage
or File API or IndexedDB or
any methodology that will let us
save state and data on the
client side.
So basically, we are
quite happy just
to be on the client.
We want to minimize
the interactions.
Why?
Because network is quite slow,
specifically on some networks,
like we have here, a
perfect example.
And we want this one connection
and that's it, so
really to do the most
from any and each
connection that we're making.
The way to do it is just to
pretend that there is no
connection, and then to
build a sync layer.
Because as you saw, to save
things locally, to save things
offline, quite easy.
The logic or the magic is in the
sync layer that does the
right things in the
right moment.
And the code here is just this
really simple API to know
where we are offline or
when we are online.
DANNY HERMES: So when asked the
question to me, are the
cloud and the client friends,
well, of course they are.
Maybe the tablet and
the network in
this room aren't friends.
But the cloud and the client
are definitely friends.
So I'm a resounding
yes on this one.
So when you're building a modern
application, you're
obviously thinking about your
client first, whether it's the
mobile web or a native
application.
But they have to rely
on the cloud.
Users are used to holding a
phone, which they treat as a
data center.
They send off queries to very
large organizations that are
doing very intense things across
the network, and they
actually expect this from
your applications.
So being able to offload
computation is
actually a big deal.
When you have lots of users,
you want a single source of
truth for data.
You want to be able to store
it somewhere other than the
client, right?
And of course, as we saw here,
we have the tablet, which
won't work, and the desktop,
which is connected to ethernet
and just fine.
So you have some users signing
in from more than one place.
So you actually need the cloud,
a server, to have this
one source of truth.
So he's saying we have to
minimize interactions.
We have to be offline.
Well, that's actually
a good thing.
It's not abandoning the cloud.
It's informing the way
that we actually
think about the cloud.
So does anyone remember DRY,
Don't Repeat Yourself?
We hear this all the time.
When we're writing code,
obviously don't write the same
thing twice, right?
Functions, classes, whatever.
But when we're talking about
the network, it's just as
important not to repeat
yourself.
Because in this situation, where
you don't have lots of
network, you can actually rely
on things that you already
know, rely on the conversations
that you've
already had, and use these nice
HTML5 technologies to
actually keep this
data around.
So we have to actually get the
most out of each and every
interaction and lick the bowl
clean like a good boy or girl.
So now I want to talk a bit
about the tools we use to
build this application.
I'd love to demo it
at some point.
So we actually use a good chunk
of the Google Cloud
Platform, which is
what I work on.
And I just want to talk about
some tools that we use to help
our friends.
So if it wasn't already
clear, the cloud
the client are friends.
So we do need a server.
But who wants to run a server?
It's hard, right?
Let's go shopping.
No.
So running a server is hard, and
we want to make it easy.
So some of the things that are
solved problems that are hard
but not worth solving are things
like traffic spikes,
communicating with your client
and your server, actually
doing authentication, trying
to figure out how to make
payloads efficient.
Like I said, these are all
solved problems, and these are
things you shouldn't be thinking
about when building
an application.
So we want to be the easy button
in as many places as we
can, and we want to push
this down extra hard.
So the biggest technology
that we run on
is Google App Engine.
Google App Engine, for those who
don't know, is a platform
as a service, which allows you
to write code in your language
of choice--
here Java, Go, Python,
and as [INAUDIBLE]
earlier today, PHP as well.
But you actually get to use
Google's infrastructure to
scale up and scale down
based on your traffic.
And in addition, you also get to
use App Engine's NoSQL data
store to store and interact with
data the same way Google
services do.
On top of Google App Engine,
we're using Google Cloud
Endpoints, which essentially
allows you to write an API
that looks like a Google API.
More about this later.
What does that mean,
a Google API?
So all modern Google
APIs have something
called a discovery document.
And it's a giant bit of JSON.
You don't have to actually
see what's on this slide.
But what this discovery document
does, it fully
specifies everything
the API can do.
So it's a language to actually
describe what payloads should
look like, what methods are
available, what kind of auth
is needed, you name it.
It describes how the
API behaves.
OK, Danny.
So what?
I don't care.
It's JSON.
Cool.
Well, so what?
By having a single document to
describe all APIs, we have
client libraries in lots and
lots of different languages
that actually understand
discovery no matter
which API it is.
And so if we bring a new API
online, these libraries out of
the box work with that API.
OK, sweet.
So with Google Cloud Endpoints,
you can write your
own API that looks like a Google
API, and this giant
tool chain is already
at your disposal.
So now you can think about
features instead of thinking
about how in the world
am I going to send my
data back and forth.
And the last piece of the puzzle
that we use, it's a
library that I wrote, so it's
definitely my favorite piece.
It's called
endpoints-proto-datastore.
And this is a way for us, on the
Python runtime of Google
App Engine, to have a way for
our data and our interface to
be the same.
So I have this simple class up
here, bank account, which says
OK, we've got an owner, which
is a string, and a balance,
which is a flow property.
So in my bank account, I have
leet dollars, right?
But my data through the client
looks exactly like the
structure that I'm defining
on the server.
And this again, data is the most
important thing in our
application.
I keep saying API, API, API.
Well, that I in API stands
for interface.
And when we're writing
applications, we care about
getting data to the server
and just moving
away from that step.
All we really want to do is
send what we know and just
move on from there.
And so by using this
library, we're
actually able to do that.
So enough about the
tools we did use.
Let's talk about how
we use them.
IDO GREEN: So we take
it from the client.
And as you saw before, and
actually now it's all here,
because some time passed, so
we have it locally here as
well, but here the most
important aspect is when we
open dev tools, we could see
literally that we have all the
metadata under local storage.
So the metadata on each and
every photo is there.
And then we use the application
File API to save
the photos themselves.
When speaking about the
application itself, so we
touched upon it, but we want
the skeleton of the app
already in our disposal.
So one interaction, and we're
getting the HTML, JavaScript,
CSS of our app.
We could download some assets,
like some images and mp3 files
if you want.
And once we do that, the
app is full functional.
And from that moment, basically
we're using the sync
layer to speak with the server
when we want this one source
of truth to broadcast all the
information to all the
different devices that we
consume and use this
application.
Photos, we love photos, and
that's why we shift our app
around them.
For photos, we have quite a lot
of abilities to save them.
In our case, we use files.
So like any other platform,
you could really use files
under the browser.
And in our case, HTML5 File
API is really nice to work
with filer.js, that Eric
Bidelman wrote, and its open
source in GitHub.
And basically, it lets you open
files like you're working
with files in Linux.
One of the things that we did
here that's another tip is
that we choose the right
tool to the job.
So when we want to save
metadata, local storage is
perfect key value.
API, when we want to store the
images, we want to store
binary data.
So it would be much more
efficient to render
the DOM with them.
And we don't need these basics
for in and out each time.
That's why we choose the File
API with the local storage to
do the best in both worlds.
When we're going and speaking
about the world out there,
it's usually not white
and black.
It's usually the golden
path between them.
And it's a complex world.
We have a wide range
of devices with
browsers, with versions.
And we want to support as
much many of course.
In our case, one of the things
that we choose is this
obstruction layer.
In our case, it's launcher.
But there are plenty of other
libraries that are out there
that basically mask the
lower level APIs that
you're going to use.
And it will do the best things
with the capabilities that
your users' browsers
are letting you do.
So if there is quite an old
browser, and it just supports,
let's say, local storage,
it will do
that, or website storage.
If it has NoSQL, the
new IndexedDB
there, it will use it.
If you need WebSQL on another
platform, it will let you do
that as well.
And it's really nice, because in
your data layer, you could
just commit the save method.
And under the seam, it will do
the right things with it.
DANNY HERMES: So we actually
can do this demo because it
doesn't require the network.
IDO GREEN: Right.
So let's switch.
DANNY HERMES: So this is
the mobile device.
IDO GREEN: And you can see now
that we've got all the photos
from before, and even
the one that I took
on the machine itself.
DANNY HERMES: Let me--
there we go.
And I have here the Chrome
Inspector open for this
application.
And we can actually see
all these assets.
So if we blow them away,
goodbye, goodbye, goodbye, and
go back to the application,
force a reload, we still have
the application, but none
of the data is there.
And we really don't
have a connection
to make this happen.
So it's really completely
happening locally.
So it's a wonderful
thing that we
actually get to demo something.
IDO GREEN: Lucky us.
DANNY HERMES: So that was
how it works offline.
And I promise, though that
button was green, that really
was offline.
But let's talk about online, how
we're actually talking to
our server when we are talking
to our server, as infrequently
as that may be.
So first, that red button, which
would have worked great,
is very simple to add if you
want to add authorization to
your application.
It's really a tiny bit of HTML,
just a button with a
sign in call back to actually
respond from the response of
whether or not sign in was
successful or not.
So this is another thing which
we don't have to do.
Easy button.
So how about discovery?
How is discovery helping us with
actually calling our API?
So in this first code snippet
up above, we see gapi dot
client dot load, and
then there's an API
name and an API version.
And this is how we're actually
loading the client library for
a specific API, in this case,
the URL Shortener API.
And once we've done that, the
gapi dot client object now has
a URL shortener object, which it
owns, which knows how to do
everything in calling
that API, which is
specified in discovery.
And through the library, we
just pass in our payload.
And from there, we get an object
which has an execute
method, and that execute method
will take a call back,
and that callback handles
the response.
Very simple, and it's based
on the discovery
document for that API.
So with Google Cloud Endpoints,
this is already at
our disposal.
So in the same fashion, we
specify our API name and
version to gapi dot client dot
load, but we also need to
specify an API route because
we can't host our APIs on
googleapis.com if we're
not Google, right?
And then to actually call the
API, it's the exact same
thing, gapi dot client,
API name, the
resource, then the method.
And you got it.
It's the exact same thing.
So I got this.
So what happened to minimizing
interactions?
So there was actually a bad
thing in there, which goes
against these things we
were saying before.
Gapi dot client dot load
actually uses a network call
every time we want to
talk to a new API.
So if we are in these conditions
where we don't have
a great network connection,
wasting one request could make
a difference between actually
retrieving a photo and making
a user's experience
better or not.
So to get the most out of it, we
have to tweak this a little
bit and get our hands dirty,
but not too dirty.
So if you were to pop open the
Chrome dev tools and check out
the network for a typical
request, you would see a giant
waterfall with a bunch of
RPCs down the left.
And one of those RPCs really
isn't too complex.
It's a standard path based on
where your application lives.
And then the actual payload
takes a method name, so here
picturesque photo list when we
want to list photos, and then
the actual payload as params.
So constructing one of these,
not so difficult.
But we wanted to make things
easier, right?
So never fear.
GAPI actually provides us a way
to do this without wasting
that network request on
GAPI client load.
So we can actually create the
RPC request by hand using
gapi.client and call it in the
exact same fashion by passing
a call back to execute.
So it's OK.
We can still use it.
And this is how we're
calling offline.
So now that we know how to call
offline, let's actually
see how we're doing this, not
in the abstract, but in the
applied sense in our
application.
IDO GREEN: So we all know, and
we spoke about the separation
between our data and the views,
and here when we are
taking a photo, one of the most
important aspect is that
today, modern browsers, you
put in this one line, and
basically you're getting the
ability to go to the camera
itself, and in some cases, to
the file system that you have
on the device, and to
choose the camera.
So you don't need any other apps
or any other libraries in
order to support this close
nature to the methods of the
device itself.
When we come in to do it in our
own application, what we
have here in store is
our own data layer.
And we have the callbacks just
to make sure that we'll be
able to respond to the things
that we make in the
configuration of it.
But then the beauty is that
we have the save click.
And basically, we just need
to focus on that.
Our add photo method is asking
us what we'll do beneath it in
the sync layer.
So for us now as developers that
are using this library,
we just want to save
the photo.
We don't care about if
it's locally, if it's
in the cloud, whatever.
We just know that it
would be saved.
And then the codec will return
and let us know what
happened with it.
So we'll communicate it
to the view itself.
DANNY HERMES: So on the server,
when that add photo
request comes through, in the
same way we defined a bank
account using
endpoints-proto-datastore, we
define a photo with the same
data that we expect to send in
our interface.
And with that, there's
a nice bit of sugar.
There's a decorator provided,
photo dot method, which allows
us to decorate a method, which
will expect to actually
receive a native photo
object based on the
data from the request.
So here, we could do some things
to validate the request
after it comes in, but
essentially, all we really
want to do is store it.
So we call photo dot put to save
that in the App Engine
data store.
IDO GREEN: And in the client,
when we basically use this
separation between our data and
our views, what we did is
just listening to the online
navigator, and you could see
quite nicely here what's
happening.
So let's see this piece of code
and walk you through it.
Basically, we have the task
object that know how to handle
our calls to the API itself, and
we have some payloads and
some metadata on our photos.
And when we go in and we want
to active a new task,
basically we see if our
user is logged in,
and here we'll know.
In case it doesn't login because
we had some problems
like in our demo, we go to this
special queue and just
put it, and we'll wait until it
would be authenticated and
log into our app.
In the case that it is logged
in, we just need to check with
navigator online if we are
online or offline, and that in
case we are online, we just want
to call the task itself
and do the best in terms of
going local storage or moving
it to the cloud.
And if it's not online for some
reason, or we got some
flaky connections, we just add
it to this queue of offline
tasks that we'll run over and
over to make sure when we have
connection, to just take
those tasks and
send them to the server.
The beauty here is that we
always take the photo and
immediately save it locally,
but then when we have
connection, we'll sync it
to the server itself.
DANNY HERMES: All right.
So sorry about that.
We're actually going to
try to demo something.
They've got some hardware which
will let us get ethernet
into that tablet.
So after we create a photo,
there's really only one other
thing we want to do for this
application, which is getting
photos potentially from other
devices that we have saved for
our account.
So we're actually going to--
this is the point where the
server doing the expensive
things comes into place.
But in doing those expensive
things, we have to keep
something in mind.
Minimize interactions, if
it wasn't clear already.
So what are some things
that we're doing?
We're loading photos in the
order that the server learned
about them.
And so by doing this, we
actually have a time stamp,
which is sort of the latest
date that our client knows
that it talked to the server.
And of course, in the same way
we implemented the sync layer
with create, when it's time to
actually talk to the API, if
we're not online, we're not
signed in, we defer it into
some kind of task.
Back to the slides, please.
Yeah.
So on the client--
IDO GREEN: On the client,
what we do here is
basically quite simple.
We're getting the local photos
first and getting
a remote call back.
And now that we got all the
local photos first, we're
getting some metadata with
them, and one of the most
important aspect is
the last update.
So we'll call the server with
this attribute and making sure
that we're just getting the
data of the photos that we
don't have locally.
And that will, of course,
improve the performance, and
basically will reduce the time
and the time around it we are
spending just to get
all the data back.
As you can see, in the client,
it's quite simple.
The not problematic but
challenging aspect is on the
server side.
So let's see how we're
doing there.
DANNY HERMES: Yeah.
So on the server, we're trying
to make our queries more
intelligent and make our server
work harder so that our
clients don't have to.
So what we're actually going
to be doing is creating an
index for sort of more
complex interactions.
So by default, the App Engine
NoSQL Datastore will create an
index for every property
that you have, unless
you tell it not to.
So if you want to know every
photo that I own with title of
fu, it can do it for
you out of the box.
But if you wanted something more
complex, like a composite
of some properties, like here we
see owner and updated, you
would have to specify that
in index.yaml file.
It's just a specification when
you deploy your application.
So this actually makes it
a little more expensive.
Every time we have to write our
entity to the data store
when we're saving the data
that we received from our
clients, we also have to create
a log and an index to
actually reference later when
we're doing these queries.
But the advantage is when our
client makes the request, it's
way faster.
So to actually provide this
through our interface, the
library
endpoints-proto-datastore
actually provides us with
some extra sugar.
Other than properties to be
persisted, we also have a
property called endpoints alias
property, as you see
here, which allows us to have
fields which are only a part
of the interface and never
get stored anywhere.
And so for us to actually let
the client ask us, hey, I know
about everything up until
20 minutes ago.
Can you give me everything
since 20 minutes ago?
We have to give them a way to
send 20 minutes ago, right?
So we have an endpoints
alias property.
And the real work here is
happening in a setter.
So in that setter,
there's really
three things that happen.
So the first thing, we take the
value from the request.
We try to turn it from a string
to a native Python
daytime object.
If we can't do it, we raise
what's called an endpoints dot
bad request exception.
And for those familiar with HTTP
status codes, that tells
the client, hey, here's a 400.
You sent me bad data.
Send me good data or
don't talk to me.
And of course, if we did get
good data, then we take the
query associated with the
request, and we are able to
add a filter, which here says
photo dot updated greater than
or equal to last updated.
So what this does, it takes our
data and says we only want
the things which have been
updated since, for example, 20
minutes ago, whatever
time stamp came
in through the request.
And finally, when we're actually
serving this request,
in the same way we got a photo
dot method decorator, we have
a photo dot query decorator,
which allows us to interact
directly with a data store
query, instead of directly
with the data, the photo
from the request.
And so we want to order that
query by when it was updated.
And by doing this, if a user has
to actually page through a
results set, they will
get them in the order
from oldest to newest.
And so, for example, if you
drop your connection while
you're paging through a results
set, you'll actually
be able to say, well, it used
to be that I knew about
everything up until
20 minutes ago.
Now I know about everything
until 10 minutes ago, and so I
don't have to waste that query
for the time in between.
So that was everything that we
would have showed in the demo,
some other things that we would
have like to have done,
and which we will be adding to
the open source code for this
application.
One would be sharing.
So we actually did implement
this before, and we were able
to create an access control
list, or an apple, for every
photo, and allow users with
Google+ share intents to
actually have a native Google+
share button and share their
photos with other users.
And it would again be based
on auth and fairly easy.
In addition, we were downscoping
the photos,
shrinking them so they would fit
in the Google App Engine
data store.
There are many pieces of the
Google Cloud Platform that
address storage.
And so Google Cloud Storage,
or the Google App Engine
Blobstore, are probably a better
place for large and
high quality photos, rather than
the data store, which in
the same way that local storage
was a good place to
actually store metadata, while
the local file system was a
good place to store photos, we
have the data store as a good
place for metadata and a nice
bucket type system like cloud
storage, which is a good
place for photos.
IDO GREEN: Yeah.
Take a deep breath.
So we tried to tell you a story
and communicate some
important aspect that
we found compelling.
One is that Google App Engine
and specifically Google Cloud
Endpoint is powerful service
that you might want to check
out in your next API service
product that you're building.
Or we think about performance
and try to minimize the
connections and optimize each
and every connection that
you're doing to the server.
Use obstructions layer and do
clear separation between your
data and the views.
It will be much more
maintainable code.
And as you all know, you're
reading code much more than
you're writing it, so you do
want the shortest possible
clear code in your app.
Leverage modern browser
features.
So we have actually on
the mobile browsers
quite a lot of features.
And a site like caniuse.com
could reveal to you all the
new APIs that mobile browser
are supporting, and we have
great adoption in that field.
So just use them.
We have some really nice talks
today, tomorrow, and on Friday
that are addressing it, and
we highly encourage you
to check them out.
There are a few options here.
Danny chose his favorite.
I chose mine.
But feel free to
check them out.
Some compelling stories about
how to do interesting things
in the cloud and on
the mobile web.
Thank you very much
for your time.
We do have seven minutes, and
would be more than happy to
try and answer your questions.
[APPLAUSE]
DANNY HERMES: In theory,
we could do the demo.
IDO GREEN: If you have
any questions, just
please come to the mic.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
IDO GREEN: Hi.
DANNY HERMES: Howdy.
AUDIENCE: I've been using Cloud
Endpoints for some time,
and it's really, really cool.
One of the things that is
probably out of the scope of
this conference,
access control.
I mean, it's kind of a huge
beast to handle sometimes, so
I would love to see
elegant ways of
handling access control.
DANNY HERMES: Sure, sure.
I don't know that there's
a question there.
But I will address sort of
the general concept.
So with access controls,
we're essentially--
every user, especially when
you're doing Google+ sign in,
you get access to their Google+
ID via the scopes that
they allow.
And so there's sort of a
global ID for accounts.
And so what we're using, we're
allowing the data store to
actually have just a list of
account IDs associated with
every photo.
And then, in addition to that,
to make queries for somebody
else's stuff that I was
allowed to see.
We would also, on our user
objects, where we were storing
our created user accounts, we
would keep a list of all the
other users that had shared
stuff with them.
And so by doing so, as sort of
a first order implementation,
we were able to actually to
utilize the data store and
queries from App Engine to
make it appear fast.
But as far as something native,
there's not anything
that I know of.
This mic's not on.
AUDIENCE: Operate on the Google+
sign in plus endpoints
integration.
Because for plus log in, you
need to request a difference
code than for endpoints,
right?
The user emails code versus
that plus [INAUDIBLE].
DANNY HERMES: So the question
was he wanted us to elaborate
on how you can use endpoints
and G+ sign
in at the same time.
So what actually happens with
endpoints for typical OAuth is
you need the email scope and
sort of nothing else.
And G+ sign in requires the
user info profile scope.
But you can actually
combine the two.
So you have a token which has
both scopes on it, and either
ID tokens or bearer tokens can
be used with endpoints.
And so if you actually send a
bearer token, it will still
check out that it has
the email scope.
It's only in the ID token case
where that will fail since you
don't just have the
email scope.
IDO GREEN: Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: On the client side,
in this example, it looked
like all the data was
kind of dynamic.
I was wondering if you have any
guidance around what would
traditionally be the static
part of the pages that are
filled in with the dynamic data
with the idea that I want
to cache this and have it
available somewhat offline.
IDO GREEN: Yeah, so actually
we couldn't show it, but in
our demo, we had the structure
of the app itself, which
wasn't dynamic at all.
So we have all the
assets with us.
All the nice button and the
footer and the header are
actually being fetched
in the first call.
And from that on, once we have
the skeleton of the app, it
could be a background image,
it could be some
music file if you like.
Once we have all that, then
we're fetching everything
dynamically.
And it's actually a phenomenon
that we see in lots of
different apps, native end
mobile webs, where you have
the skeleton, and then the
data itself is being
retrieving.
All the apps containing some
long list of things.
It could be a mail.
It could be a social app.
It could be a photo app.
It's usually the skeleton just
like we did, and then all the
photos there.
I didn't mention it, but the
app itself is live at that
URL, and you're more than happy
to check it when you
have connection and see
that it works for you.
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: Cool, I maybe have
two questions for you guys.
Is endpoints still considered
experimental?
DANNY HERMES: It's considered
preview.
The language around that
and cloud platform
has recently changed.
We have a product manager here
who could probably talk your
ear off about it, but I
know a fair amount.
So preview essentially is our
way of saying it's not
completely general availability
yet, which is our
generic term for like no labels
at all other than just
use it, right?
But we're committed to it, we're
committed to improving
it, and we're actively working
on it very quickly.
AUDIENCE: So that's my
second question.
I'm the developer at
the Ferris web
framework for App Engine.
And I'm planning on integrating
Cloud and
Endpoints with that
so that Ferris--
DANNY HERMES: Sorry, what
framework did you say?
AUDIENCE: Ferris.
Ferris by--
DANNY HERMES: Ferris,
like Ferris wheel?
AUDIENCE: Like Ferris Bueller.
DANNY HERMES: OK,
that works too.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's
to be lazy.
It's kind of similar to Flask
and Django in a way,
specifically for App Engine.
So we're planning on integrating
Cloud Endpoints
into Ferris so you can share the
same code between the two.
So the big question there is,
how much more is the API going
to change from this point.
DANNY HERMES: Yeah, I can't
answer a question like that.
AUDIENCE: You can't answer
a question like that.
OK, cool.
Yeah, so I was just wondering
how much we could expect--
new features is great, but I
mean like just kind of the
core, is the core kind of
solid, do you guys feel?
DANNY HERMES: So Cloud Endpoints
is actually more
than just an App Engine feature
because it uses a
shared infrastructure that all
of Google's APIs use as well.
And so there's a fair amount
of discovery itself is a
specification, and there's also
a back end configuration,
which allows us to register with
that shared API service
and say this is what I look
like, this is the kind of
things that I want you to send
me, this is the kind of things
that I'll give back
to you, and other
related things like auth.
So this is an active
conversation
which we have a lot.
So I I'm happy to talk more
about it after, but.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
It's great so far.
ProtoRPC and everything
involved in that
looks great so far.
Thank you, guys.
DANNY HERMES: OK, cool.
IDO GREEN: OK, thank
you very much.
Bye bye.
[APPLAUSE]